PHILIP GREENSPUN: Hi.
We're going to talk
about seaplanes.
And there's two
different designs.
You can have a
boat hull seaplane,
or you can have a conventional
airplane on floats.
So there at the bottom left
is part of the Grumman series.
They made a huge number of
these around World War II,
and many of them
are still flying.
You can see always probably
15 or 20 of these at Oshkosh
every year in different sizes.
The Widgeon is the smallest.
The Albatross is the biggest.
I forget if that's a Martin
Mars up there on the top left.
There are some truly
huge seaplanes.
Boeing, Sikorsky,
and Martin, I think,
all made huge seaplanes during
World War II and just before.
The bush pilots don't like
the small boat hull seaplanes,
like the Lake Amphibian.
And I guess the
Icon they probably
wouldn't like if it ever did
ship out there to Alaska.
I think one issue with
the boat hull planes is
they are very hard to dock.
You have to design some
special dock for them.
They're really designed
more for beaching,
whereas the float
planes very naturally
come up to a dock like a boat.
That's one issue.
So yeah, you might think those
float planes look so unstable,
but the bush pilots love them.
It's hard to get on and
off the water, which
is why a practical seaplane
really should have,
in most cases, a
turbo prop engine
to get enough power to
really get off the water.
So we do have, in
Alaska, locally--
it's called Maine.
There's a fair amount of
seaplane flying up there.
These are a couple of
US government planes.
If you want to know
why your taxes are
going in the direction
that they're going,
look on the bottom right.
That was the government's.
I saw these two plane
side by side on the ramp.
Portland, Maine
has a wonderful FBO
called MAC Jets, which
is very hospitable.
They have crew cars,
reasonably priced 100 low lead.
They're really just operating it
as a gift to the piston crowd,
of course.
They're really there
for the turbine--
as a business, they're
there for the Jets.
But it's a great place
that you can use, and jump
in the crew car, go into town.
But anyway, on the
ramp, I happened
to see there's a little Piston
Cessna on floats that they
bought 15 or 20 years ago
for Fish and Wildlife patrol
or something.
I think this is a federal
government airplane.
And now, they have
this monster thing
that they're replacing
it with, that has
a fire-breathing turboprop
engine that probably costs five
times as much per hour to run.
OK.
Every year in September, there
is the Moosehead Lake Seaplane
Fly-in.
And you might ask, can you fly
in the air in the East Coast
Aero Club plane
that you've rented?
The answer is yes,
although you probably
can't fly back out if you
choose the lake as your landing
destination.
But there is a wheeled
airport there as well
that's pretty reasonable.
I think it's about
a 4,000-foot runway.
So if the weather's nice,
that's a great place
to go, up in Moosehead Lake.
It's a long drive.
It's about probably a
five-hour drive from here.
The hard thing
about seaplanes is
if the float is all
the way in the water,
it will never take off.
There's so much drag.
You have to get up
on the step, which
if you're a boater corresponds
to getting up on the plane,
I guess, of a planing haul.
So basically, you can't have
the entire float in the water
if you ever want to take off.
Let's just show a short
YouTube video here.
We have no sound.
Oh well, that's fine.
So you can see this
Caravan on floats.
I think it's a Caravan.
It's beginning to
get up on the step.
And finally, it can break loose.
Anyway, that's how it's done.
Crosswind landing--
this is how it's
done, according to the FAA.
So the FAA's mission--
[LAUGHTER]
The FAA's mission
is, in addition
to regulating aviation,
they're explicitly
supposed to promote aviation.
It's a rare agency.
So part of their mission is
to encourage people to fly.
And this is the best that
they can do for seaplanes.
So it does tell you--
Like I was telling you,
the problem with seaplanes
is if you make an error on
Hanscom on Runway 29, first
of all, it's 150 feet wide.
And the gear on your airplane
might only be 10 feet wide.
So you can slide quite a bit,
left or right, before you even
leave the pavement.
If you do leave the
pavement, you're
skidding along the
grass, and the owner
is going to have some harsh
words for you, perhaps.
But otherwise, nothing too
dramatic is going to happen.
Glassy-- this is the
FAA's glassy water landing
demonstration.
So if there is no wind at all,
you might think, that's great.
That's perfect for
seaplane flying.
It's hard to judge
where the water is.
A little bit of wind that
causes some ripples on the water
makes it much easier
to judge your distance.
So here's your alternatives.
You can not flare at all, and
crash into the water that way.
Or you can flare too high,
and then crash into the water.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Those are
the only possibilities.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Those
are the only possibilities.
What's the question,
radar altimeter?
AUDIENCE: No.
So hello.
For seaplanes, do you wait until
you have seen VR before while
taking off, or do you have
the floats clear the water
and [? take ?] [? off? ?]
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
The question is,
do you wait until
VR to take off,
or do you just wait till the
floats have cleared the water
and take off?
That's a good question.
It's so inefficient to be
dragged into the water.
I think you lift out of the
water just as soon as you can.
And then you'll
probably float-- you'll
fly along the ground
effect for a little bit,
and then finally take off.
But yeah, just like on a soft
field, like slightly muddy
grass or something, the
best thing you can do
is to get away from the
surface that's dragging on you.
Great question.
All right.
Here's the docking and beaching.
So one challenge
with a seaplane,
if you're all by yourself, is
you have to be tremendously
agile and nimble to get out
of the plane, kill the engine,
scramble around usually
the front of the airplane
and the propeller-- because
you're sitting on the left,
and the passengers are going
to get off on the right--
and tie up the
airplane to the dock.
It's very hard to do.
That's one of the
hardest things,
I think, about seaplanes.
And also, if the magnetos
aren't perfectly grounded,
airplane engines can
start by themselves.
After saying we shouldn't
tell you stuff that's scary--
if it's not perfectly
grounded by that switch,
and you don't starve
the engine of the fuel
by killing it with
the mixture, it
may be able to start all
by itself, at least run
for a half a rotation or full
rotation, and hurt somebody.
So you always want to be
cautious around propellers
and not spin them.
But of course, if you're
trying to get around
the front of your
seaplane, the propeller
is the most obvious
thing to grab onto.
Anyway, I don't
think I would ever
want to fly a seaplane unless
there were dock handlers who
were going to deal with
that part of welcoming
the airplane to the dock
and tying it all up.
But of course, the folks in
Alaska do this all the time.
So have respect when
you see a seaplane.
So there are a lot of bad
things that you can do.
Believe it or not, landing
in the sea is something
that's almost-- in practice,
it's almost impossible
on a seaplane because there's
too much in the way of waves,
that really-- for
harbors, rivers, lakes,
if you have more
than a foot of--
if the waves are more
than about a foot,
it just bangs up the seaplane
so much that it will be damaged.
Landing the amphibious
plane with the wheels
down is one of the
most common mistakes.
You might think
software would fix
this, that if you have
a database of where
all the runways are in the US,
you have a database of where
the lakes are, and
other bodies of water--
but you don't even
really need that.
So you could have a lot.
You could have a
camera out in the front
that can tell the difference
between water and not water.
So you would think that
the airplane would provide
significant assistance in
configuring an amphibious plane
with having their wheels down
for a hard surface or just
the bare floats for water.
And there's very little
of that, unfortunately.
There's certainly nothing
like the intelligence
that I'm describing.
You might be able
to press a button
and have the plane tell you,
with the synthesized voices
and aftermarket thing, "the
wheels are down for runway
landing" or something.
So one common thing
that people forget--
not that common, but this is
an illustration of why you
might want a two-pilot crew.
But there's a video
that's linked here
from the slide about a father--
so he sounds like a good
pilot, and a careful pilot.
He was with his son, and
he left the wheels down,
landed in the water, flipped it
over, and the son was killed.
Really tragic.
So watch that if
you want to cry.
But anyway, I think
it's a good illustration
of a seaplane-- an amphibious
seaplane operation is
a great example of where a
two-pilot crew with a checklist
would be very unlikely to
have that kind of accident.
So it also illustrates
how it's too bad
that these manned
airplanes don't
have one one-hundreth of the
intelligence of a DGI drone.
There are rare exceptions.
Like I said, at Burning Man,
the terrain warning system had
to be silenced because it was
freaking out that we were not
going to make it, even
though there was a 5,000-foot
temporary runway that
had been rolled out there
by the Burners--
the uber Burners.
OK.
Salt waters-- people
do this commercially,
but the airplane
has to be hosed off
every day because the saltwater
is corrosive, even to aluminum.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Lakes and
harbors tend to have
a lot of people on them.
How do you avoid hitting
a swimmer or a boater?
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
Yeah, how do you
avoid hitting swimmers and
boaters in lakes and harbors?
Yeah, that's one of the
challenges of seaplanes.
If you're cleared to
land in an airport,
the air traffic controller
has looked out on the runway
and made sure that there's
no other aircraft, pretty
sure that there is no
deer on the runway.
The seaplane you
have to orbit around.
It's a little bit like landing
a helicopter off airport
to really make sure that
there's nobody in a canoe.
I will tell you that for my
seaplane training up in Maine,
I have a seaplane rating
that I got up in Maine.
And there's a great school
up there called Twitchell's.
But anyway, yeah,
kayakers can paddle
pretty fast when they see a
seaplane in their vicinity.
Head towards the shore.
But yeah, there could
be a log in the water.
So there's just-- there
are hazards that you
can't control and get rid of.
So the accident rate
does tend to be higher.
In the military-- I think
there's a slide later where we
talk about that--
they've gotten away from
seaplanes and into helicopters
for that reason.
Just so you know,
the helicopter--
you can be down to within two
feet of the ground and say,
I don't like what I see.
I'm going to go somewhere else.
The propeller tends
to get beaten up.
You'll see some
seaplane designs where
the propeller is up
high and in the back,
and that's to keep the water--
the propeller's going near
supersonic speeds at the tips.
So if it gets water on
it, it'll be eroded.
Same deal with flying your
airplane in heavy rain.
You can get erosion on the
leading edges of the wing
and on the prop.
All right.
So yeah, the
seaplane pilot skills
include a lot more judgment.
To some extent, they'll be
the dimensions of these lakes.
And in Alaska, there's even
a lighted water runway.
But generally speaking, you
don't have a lot of information
to go by.
So you've got to evaluate
all this stuff by yourself.
One thing you can do--
I'll use this coffee
cup as an example.
You can usually see where
the wind's coming from.
If there's trees
all around the lake,
the lake will be calm right
next to-- let's assume
this coffee cup is a tree.
The lake will be calm and
glassy right next to the tree.
And that tells you the wind
is coming from this direction,
because that part of the lake is
being sheltered from the wind.
So you can actually read
the wind off the lake
by looking at which
parts are rippled
and which parts are glassy.
But you still have
to decide, right,
are there floating
logs in the water?
Are there swimmers?
Are there boats?
Here are some unusual skills
that you have to have--
well, you might have to have.
After maintenance-- or to
get the airplane maintained.
Ah!
All right.
So that was straight
floats in the grass.
So at the end of
the season, if you
want to get the
airplane maintained,
there's not a lot of
airplane mechanics hanging
around the typical lake.
So you just land
it on the floats
in the grass at an airport.
And what about when
you want to get it out?
Yeah.
To get the sound,
watch that at home.
So as I said earlier, the
problem with seaplanes
is that it's just a lot less
forgiving than a hard surface
runway, which is the most
forgiving environment.
You can enhance that safety
with a two-pilot crew,
especially an experienced
seaplane pilot, or--
fair stuff, it'll
be on the test--
you can learn about
accident reporting.
So this is a different part
of the federal regulations.
This is the part that
regulates what the NTSB does--
National Transportation
Safety Board.
So first, they define
what an accident is.
So there has to be
a serious injury.
And if you go in
there, they define
what a serious injury is.
And I think substantial
damage to the aircraft--
if it's just the landing
gear that's a bit trashed,
I don't think that qualifies.
If somebody dies within
30 days of the accident,
it becomes fatal.
Here's your definition
of serious injury--
not too much fun.
You have to immediately notify
the NTSB if the flight controls
malfunction.
They don't really care if the
Lycoming or continental piston
engine fails in some way.
But if the flight
controls fail, and you
can't bank your Cessna
or Piper or Cirrus,
that's something they'll
want to hear about.
If more than half of your
glass cockpit goes dark,
they want to hear about that.
I think 830.15 is in
the test something.
There's time
periods, like report
within 10 days of the accident.
Oh yeah, and required
info when notifying.
OK.
So the bottom line
on seaplanes is
that it does combine the
hazards of a boat and a plane.
And therefore, you
need the skills
of both a sailor and a pilot
to manage those hazards.
On the other hand, I
think it's a lot of fun.
When the Icon first came
out at $100,000 and change,
I thought, oh, this
would be great.
We'll just get one of these.
We'll split it four ways.
We'll keep it at
Hanscom, and we'll
go up for a 15-minute
flight to New Hampshire--
splash and dash, come back,
and it'll be really cool.
Now that it's a $400,000
airplane, it's not enough--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
seven days.
[? But ?] [? that ?] said,
what does overdue mean?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Overdue.
The question is-- go
back to that slide.
Yeah-- file a report
within seven days
if an aircraft is overdue.
So that means you expect
an airplane to come back
from the fishing camp in
Alaska and it hasn't returned.
So you don't know if
it's crashed or not.
That was like me.
Remember I told you that story
about landing a PBK in Atlanta?
And I forgot to
close my flight plan.
And so my Diamond Star
was considered overdue.
And I kept rejecting calls from
an unfamiliar phone number--
not my proudest moment.
All right.
So insurance is kind of
expensive, as I noted,
especially for the amphibs.
An airplane on straight floats
isn't that much more expensive
to insure than a
regular airplane.
Actually, that's a great
way to evaluate risk.
If an insurance company
is willing to write
a policy for a Cessna on floats,
it can't be all that dangerous.
But like I said, the
military has decided,
let's do most of the things
we used to do with seaplanes
with helicopters.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Insurance [INAUDIBLE]
delayed [INAUDIBLE]..
What about-- so
our insurance-- we
[? haven't ?] had
personal insurance.
So if we fly, but
we hurt ourselves,
is our medical coverage
going to cover that?
So you're saying [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Oh, no.
I think-- so the
question is, does
your regular medical insurance
cover an injury from flying?
Sure.
Yeah, there's no
exclusion for that.
I think somebody if you
get an umbrella liability
policy they say,
well, that's great
but we're not going to
like to add $5 million
if you injure somebody
with your Cessna.
So they can have exclusions.
AOPA has a big insurance
business, actually,
selling life insurance at pretty
reasonable rates to pilots.
So there, again,
that tells you--
when your friend
says, you're stupid,
why would you fly a
Piper or a Cessna?
That thing's old.
It doesn't look safe.
You can say, well, insurance
companies aren't stupid,
and they have a huge business
marketing life insurance
to the members of AOPA,
who are all flying
little airplanes like this.
And it's only a 10% higher
rate than what you can
get in the market elsewhere.
Of course, pilots are
healthier than the--
that's one issue, right?
Since pilots by definition
have passed a medical exam,
they tend to be a little
bit healthier than average.
Same reason, like the
military-- the death rate
of people who serve
in the military
is quite a bit lower than the
death rate of the same age
people who are in the
civilian workforce,
partly because not that many
of them are actually in combat,
and partly because
the military rejects
people who are unhealthy.
So you're not going to
die of cancer at age 23
if you're in the military,
because they would have not let
you enlist,
probably, if they saw
that you were suffering from
the beginning stages of cancer.
All right.
Light sport flying boats--
Searey is fun.
This is a real one.
There are 700 of
these out there,
and they sell it as a kit.
And they also sell it
as a built airplane.
So here it is--
look how much fun.
Somebody put one
of these on a yacht
and flew it in all different
parts of the world.
They would take off--
I guess they would winch
it down into the water,
take off, fly around, and
then winch it back up.
And I think they were in some
fairly open oceans at the time.
And the thing survived,
so that's pretty cool.
They stuff a Garmin G3X
glass cockpit in there.
And that's the same thing
as the Gamebird has.
The white sport folks
have a lot of flexibility.
It has a road tax engine,
which is conventional.
The Icon A5 is the airplane--
see, look at Oshkosh.
Their booth is always packed.
People love it.
People want it.
And it's one of
the few airplanes
that's marketed to people
that don't have any flying
experience.
I wrote a review of it
in 2010, saying that it
would be available in 2014.
I think it had been
originally promised for 2012.
So it's just coming out.
These composite planes
are hard to manufacturer.
I talked to the Gamebird guys.
They said they spend 500 hours--
500 person hours--
prepping the airplane
to be painted, just like
sanding, and smoothing
everything to be painted.
So I think it's just very
hard to make these things
at an economical price.
We still don't have sound,
I don't think, do we?
Here's my review of the plane.
I made this little
video that was fun.
Well, I thought it was fun.
I'm sure Icon doesn't
think it's fun.
All right.
Questions about seaplanes?
Who wants one?
Who would buy an Icon if
it were reasonably priced?
A lot of people's questions.
AUDIENCE: You were talking about
[INAUDIBLE] sides of a lake,
and don't land out at sea.
But what would be your
opinion about the Great Lakes?
I know sometimes the waves
can be higher than a foot.
But when you just look
at it, [INAUDIBLE]
judge what the
waves [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIP GREENSPUN: The question
is, what would, by my opinion,
be a landing in the Great Lakes?
I think people do a lot
of flying of seaplanes
up in the Great Lakes.
But there again, the Great
Lakes-- there are harbors.
There are calmer areas.
So I think they're
not really landing
in the middle of
the Great Lakes.
And then, they don't
say, I just want
to go to the middle of
Lake Superior and fish
off the float for a while.
They're going to
some destination,
and by definition,
the destination
will have a calmer area
for boats to hang out in.
I think there's actually
a commercial seaplane
service that's starting up
between Manhattan and Boston.
So you'll go to the--
there's a seaplane--
I should have mentioned this.
For helicopters, there are
helipads all around Manhattan.
So you can actually go to
the downtown Wall Street
heliport, land--
it used to be really cheap.
It was $75 an hour for
parking, I think, or maybe $25.
I don't know, it wasn't that
much more than parking a car.
Go in and have lunch.
Now, they've leased
those helipads
to some government crony
monopoly that owns all three
of them.
And they cranked the rates up
by a factor of four immediately.
But anyway, I don't know
if it's the same company,
but they have a public seaplane
port there on the East River.
And I think it's a Cape
Air affiliate, maybe,
that's going to start
operating downtown to downtown
in a Cessna Caravan on floats.